it was kind of trademark but it was
vintage boris johnson wasn't it
uh it was as i thought it would be
he was talking about his greatest hits
it had huge
with sadness
and it was also very dignified actually
um a very dignified speech i thought in
which he
uh held his head high he accepted that
he didn't want to leave and some of the
things that you know uh struck me he
said of course it was painful not to be
able to see through the project and as i
said before he rolled out the greatest
hits he said how proud he was uh to have
got brexit
done and to put he said uh and to give
the country back the power to make its
own laws that's how he put it uh he
talked about leveling up we must keep on
levelling up and we must fight for the
freedom of ukraine for as long as it
takes he then went on to say
of course it is painful not to see
the projects through that i wanted to
and then he said in a characteristically
humorous
uh way he said but the herd
has moved and when the herd
moves it moves quickly and then he said
no one is remotely indispensable he'd
said how much he wanted
to
stay on and then he said that the
darwinian system as he put it will
produce another leader who he said he
would give as much support as he could
and then he touched upon
his divisiveness
because he's batted it off all the time
but he said i know that some of you many
of you he said will be relieved and some
disappointed by my resignation and he
said
he was so sad to believe in the best job
in the world as he described it and then
he finished off by thanking the public
for giving him as he said the immense
privilege of being able to serve as the
prime minister he said being prime
minister is an education
in itself and he said about the
boundless british energy and enthusiasm
that he had met around the country and
then he finally ended uh with you know
he is a journalist he's a good writer
and he does good oratory he said
it might feel dark now but the future
together is golden and with that the
applause there were no tears uh massive
applause and he went back and he also
thanked his wife carrie johnson who was
watching on with their nine-month-old
baby romney oh yeah it was i thought
beth it was interesting talking
beforehand about the emotion of other uh
resignation states that we've seen
and in recent days we've been told that
boris johnson is in buoyant spirits and
there were no tears obviously from the
prime minister but i did get a sense we
got a flicker of emotion from him
perhaps more than he usually
shows when he was talking about how sad
he was to get the best job in the world
as she was saying talking quite frankly
about the reason that he's continued to
fight on so long perhaps a little bit of
an acknowledgement and that he has been
trying to hang on to the job until it
just became impossible yeah and you know
and and he talked about you know he
started off by thanking the british
people for that huge mandate he wanted
it to be known that he was a winner once
and he won the biggest majority since
margaret thatcher and he wanted to
remind everyone of that and he explained
that that was the reason that he clung
on for so long that he felt that he had
been given a mandate
by the people and that mandate he felt
stood but he said as he acknowledged the
hard moved against him and once that
happened there really was nowhere else
for him to go but you know i didn't
expect to see boris johnson
shed a tear the most emotion i've ever
seen in boris johnson is him drop he
drops sometimes drops his head but he
wanted that to be a moment where he
projected confidence and optimism they
are the tickets if you like that
attracted the public to him in the first
place the can-do optimism the boris
johnson boosterism as we used to call it
and and really that that speech i think
had bucket loads of that in terms of the
delivery
but also look it's hard to hear any
prime minister talk about having to
leave that job it was hard to hear david
cameron do it theresa may boris johnson
because you know as he said it's the
best job in the world i'm sad to leave
it i didn't want to go
but i had to leave and that must be
absolutely
brutal